yo we're gave it max and we've got
everything you need to get your style
jiggy with it Wild Wild West as
professional man stylist Eve and I have
to look amazing 24 7 52 365 why you ask
never know when you're gonna run into a
millionaire how some of you guys get
squeamish when it comes time to talk
beauty but it's y2k you're gonna need
tips of course we can't give you all the
tips no take years hundreds of years but
we can give you three tips although this
guy doesn't hate them Gabe looks great
today yeah there are two secrets to
having beautiful hair the first secret
is to have some or buy horses the second
secret is using product but which
product and how much product these are
personal questions you'll have to find
the answer to yourself but the answer is
gel and a lot of it of course every head
of hair is different maybe you have
brown hair or dark brown hair or are a
black person but whatever you have or
are your hair is going to look best if
you put a ton of product in it and use
that product to sculpt it into a faux
hawk pro tip you can make your fauxhawk
shine by adding just a little extra gel
Gabe you look great okay
so be honest guys help me out there
actually use cologne thought so you
gotta use it it's like they always say
you could look as good as a Ferrari but
it doesn't matter if you smell like a
bus picking the right cologne is all
about expressing yourself and then
letting other people smell what you just
dispensed so choose the fragrance is
right for you as long as it's not
Jasmine Jasmine's for failures once
you've got your scent apply it
conservatively to your pulse points
between one and three pumps then just
pour some down the front of your shirt
and massage them into your scalp you
don't want to overpower people with your
cologne but you want to make sure they
know who they're smelling protip spray
some cologne on your clothes every night
before you go to bed with the time
you've saved you'll only need 10-15
minutes tops to apply your de cologne
jayma always smells great do tuesday
enough hands are the doorknobs to the
soul nothing says hey this guy is a
picture of success like a pair of dark
healthy hands everyone knows how
important first impressions are and
science studies show that the first
thing attractive women and your new boss
look at is at anna see your hands not a
tanning salons won't and just your hands
so insist on it you'll be glad you did
I've got a hand into your game you close
that deal fantastic
so there you have it now if beauty is an
iceberg we just gave you the tip of the
iceberg but there's a lot more beauty
underneath the water but the tip is
enough because the tip of the iceberg
sunk the Titanic you'll be saying ciao
to the posers in no time